it's been a while i left you guys on a
cliffhanger for
four days or so and i apologize your
fingers must be hurting
last time i checked in with you we had
just finished talking about peter
schoechnick
a lawyer who after getting disbarred is
now back to filing abusive ada lawsuits
and that's
the bulk of what we're going to talk
about today but first i want to talk
about
why i didn't release the cliffhanger
part 2
the day after like i originally planned
to and it's because i got some
reasonable
criticism about my first video which was
essentially
that when i implied that david
ruthenbaler wasn't disabled just because
there was a video of him
walking around is it really fair and
leads to a culture of
judging disabled people on whether they
look disabled
in fact i invited a disabled person on
my show
to explain it better than i ever could
i'm jocelyn
and i was born with a spinal cord tumor
complications forced me to use a chair
by the age of nine
so i use a wheelchair full time now uh
in my experience
it's hard for the public to understand
uh
that people can be more disabled on some
days than
others and often the folks who have
disabilities
that are variable they face the most
sort of overt public judgment i just
think it's really important for people
to understand
that it's not the public's place to
judge
whether someone has a disability and i
totally
agree with that and i should have been
more clear in the video and also been
more clear with the audience that
for the most part individuals faking
disability really
isn't a thing so bear in mind
that everything we say on this video is
not typical
you should absolutely under no
circumstances be
checking to see if you know somebody
with a disabled parking sign
on their on their car windshield is
actually disabled in your mind because
they're walking look
clearly there are conditions which vary
day to day and just because
someone can walk one day doesn't mean
that they're fully able to walk all the
time and don't require
mobility access however there is a time
when it's materially relevant and to
talk about this i invited on
the other side of the story aka the
representative for the small businesses
who have been sued by peter streichner
this
is phil stillman i i thought his
disabilities just from the way they were
written in the complaint
sounded not believable shall we say phil
has no
problem saying that he doesn't believe
peter strzognik when he says that he has
problems with walking around but he
doesn't say this callously
he says this because how the ada works
is that
you need to have what is called an
injury in fact
one of the things you have to show in
americans with disability act litigation
is that it's not a barrier in general
but it's got to be a barrier to you
based on your own disability so for
example
if you're blind you can't sue a hotel
or another business because the aisles
are too narrow for a wheelchair
and this is one of the things that peter
storchnick
has not been able to do someone says he
never has really told anybody what his
actual problems are
one of the problems that stronach has
had had
and and for whatever reason refused to
go into detail on was how his
disabilities
um what his disabilities actually were
and how
he would be suing on a let's say
something that would affect someone in a
wheelchair
but he's not in a wheelchair so this
puts me in a really tough position
because here i am wanting to make
this video talking about this lawyer
who's hustling hundreds of small
businesses
out of thousand dollar settlements but
on the other hand
i'm having this conversation with this
disabled person telling me
rightfully so that hey disabled people
shouldn't have to
prove themselves to you in fact it's
actually also part of the ada
we're caught in a bit of attention here
because
my understanding of the ada is that it
also protects
people with disabilities from having to
be from having to have their disability
validated
for unnecessary reasons so for example
with that disability with schizophrenia
there's a lot of stigma and i wouldn't
have a good working environment if i had
to tell everybody
so i'm going back and forth between
these two interviews like yeah i kind of
agree with you oh well
i kind of agree with you and that's what
made this video so tough
and eventually i just decided to tell it
in all of its
nuanced goriness which is on the one
hand
you shouldn't judge disabled people on
the other hand
sometimes when somebody's suing hundreds
of small businesses
it might be worth looking at what their
claim to disability is
and that's exactly what stillman did
after learning that george nick had
filed hundreds of cases that had been
subsequently thrown out in arizona and
then he had been disbarred
he decided to check in destroying his
claims of being disabled
and went and captured video footage from
whence george nick visited the hotels
and here's what he found so i started
getting video surveillance showing
you know him walking in with like a
shoulder over the shoulder luggage and
pulling a big bag
and standing up just fine and walking
over to the uh to the excuse me to the
elevator
then i you know that was my first one
from one of my clients and that showed
him checking in
at the time when he's claiming that you
know he's disabled and then
i started getting some video from other
hotels showing him
literally walking all over the hotel
taking pictures and
no problems walking at all so it's it's
pretty clear now that
that it's just a fraudulent scheme
have you ever seen him on on camera in a
wheelchair kind of wheeling around
but if that's not enough he's actually
asked to take an independent medical
exam to determine
what are his problems one of my
colleagues who also was handling one of
the cases
uh got forced him to a independent
medical examination
and and the report says he doesn't
appear to have any problems walking or
anything so
the the independent medical exam report
seems
to seems to support uh the fact that he
doesn't have any problems that he claims
to have so here we're left with a weird
problem where on the one hand disabled
people want to be rightfully let alone
from constantly having
to prove themselves or somehow prove
that they are in fact as
disabled as they claim they are because
it is true
that almost no one fakes disabilities
however
it is also true that that almost is
non-zero
so what's the answer well it's a tough
issue for sure
but jocelyn says it should be done
respectfully
if in that state the way compliance is
done
is that you have to be one of these
people then i do think there's grounds
to prove to somebody maybe not the
public maybe not the media
right right at least maybe a judge or
something like that
so what's the result of all this right
after
all of it's said and done who's actually
winning here well it's certainly
not the small businesses and it's also
not the ada both jocelyn and stillman
say
that it looks just bad for the ada when
things like this
happen the only person who seems to be
winning is peter strejnik
who keeps pressuring businesses into
settlements and this has been
profitable for him in one file that i
recently saw
this lawyer who is totally disbarred he
can't seek attorney fees at all
has made over 200 thousand dollars
in settlements which is absolutely
mind-blowing but stillman says it just
only makes business sense
most companies they don't want to retain
stillman because he costs
more than getting the settlement done so
here's the business model
you know so you sue uh you sue a hotel
and the first thing they do is they call
a lawyer say hey i got this ada case
this guy's
been this part et cetera et cetera what
can i do the lawyer said oh no problem
send me a
ten thousand dollar retainer and we'll
be off to the races
and the fact of the matter is that the
client can settle these cases
probably for five grand he's picked a
sweet spot
of finance so that it makes
just more sense to not have someone like
me
on on the job but just you know pay him
money
to just get rid of it it's kind of like
protection money though isn't it
it's a racket it's a protection scheme
so where does that leave us
how do we solve that issue well the
solution stillman came up with
is surprisingly straightforward just
notify the businesses before you sue
it's a condition that before you can sue
somebody for ada violations
you have to tell them that in fact they
have an ada violation i know
sounds revolutionary i think that the
best way to deal with these things is to
make a requirement that they give before
anybody can sue
that there's there are these issues and
if they remedy those issues
they shouldn't be able to sue it all and
jocelyn agrees although
she says that there's one thing to
remember the key
point here is there is always going to
be bad people
and those bad people can't be our excuse
to alleviate every business person in
the land from
being from their their legal obligation
to be compliant to include i think it's
like
20 of the population has a disability of
some sort
well said jocelyn and to both my guests
today
stillman and jocelyn um i want to extend
my thanks
for lending me both of your expertise
and i apologize in advance that i know
that this is not a perfect video and i
hope you guys understand that i'm doing
the best i can to present these scams
with as much nuance and empathy as i can
now please enjoy as jocelyn tries to get
me canceled on the internet thanks for
taking the time appreciate it
well can i plug my channel sure yeah
um our channel is called gimpax
g-i-m-p-h-a-c-k-s
it's okay to say [ __ ] i say so
i'm not gonna say it nice try jocelyn
you almost got me but
it's 20 20 and it's the internet i ain't
taking no chances and don't forget to
smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
comes along